hello my name is Jeremy chambers and I'm
Cody Melcher this is Tara just saw and
Cody also just saw two as well
motherly yes Aronofsky a very very only
absolutely movie that I've seen is last
one oh you didn't see the wrestler oh
alright I did a little bit of research
before going to see this I knew it was
gonna be kind of like a very confusing
weird non-story sinha ballistic yeah
thing so I was prepared for that let's
just say off the bat that there's gonna
be spoilers I really think the movies up
to so much interpretation that's it's
just impossible to spoil it but I do
think that some people want to go into
it without hearing other people's
interpretation so if you don't want to
hear that click away this has been your
warning I uh that's it all right
oh you guys I am feeling some things
from that film yeah Irie have very
different reactions to yeah I I think
that I love it but I'm not sure yeah
were the first half probably of the
movie I was like okay I'm digging this I
like this I want to see where it goes
and then it jumps a sharknado and then I
was like alright I understand that I
think that a lot of people are gonna
have terrible reactions to this movie in
a way that like it made them upset or it
just didn't sit with them well or or
just take it or leave it I don't know I
I took it as like this this like
terrible thing that happens with Fame
and how it destroyed them and all of the
different steps of it and it was very
powerful to me to see it it could be
pretty pretentious in some
moments but I felt it was entirely
pretentious yeah so I I'm not usually a
fan of films like that but I dug it I
dug it it just for some reason spoke to
like the buttons in me that like we're
really effective for me I think the
endings ruined it for me
when it becomes a religious allegory oh
it's no because you're not ski just
finished Noah and it's like oh he's he's
down this rabbit hole now I actually had
not realized it was there an auskey
going in and then partway through I was
like I was this Darren Aronofsky because
I'm you can just tell a certain point
I've seen that quote an interview that
he gave where he was like yeah it's one
of those movies we can't really unscrew
it too much or just starts falling apart
and I'm like I like does like to me
that's like the donnie darko where the
writer was like well I don't even know
what it's about like I feel like there's
something there's a Chandra of movie
that's so artsy and pretentious to some
extent they try to act like oh well it's
it's not understandable as a film and
I'm like I I sometimes I don't I don't
I'm not judging on either side by
sometimes feel like that's a way to get
away with lazy writing to some extent
where it's like well it's so open to
interpretation that even I the writer do
not fully understand the movie and I'm
like I feel like somebody needs to
understand it at least I have a general
idea I definitely got the feeling then
that there was a concept and sure they
they knew what it was about sure it's
open to interpretation just towards the
audience but I do know what you mean
sure obviously someone's you know what
that I was into it y'all like I was
super connected I cried when she lost
her baby I feel like I've been kind of
Jennifer Lawrence out for a bit she was
in so much um all at once I spit in hot
seconds since I've seen her and
something and she was so like innocent
in this
and I just felt so much uncomfortable
rage for her the whole film and it was a
film that wasn't pleasant to watch no at
all it was very unlike under your skin
the whole time I was so uncomfortable
but the message that I got out of it was
like that payoff was so good I don't
know I want to see it again I want to go
like give it a few days to ruminate
within my mind and go see it again I
will say I've been playing the evil
within which is a bethesda game where I
tweeted about it recently that the
camera angles were super off and that
like you always feel like you can't
fully see what's happening and I felt
that a lot and I think that's they were
doing that anything to up the
uncomfortable factor but the shots were
like you were always like just like
really yeah and so I felt like a little
claustrophobic in that which helps you
feel just like can I just see everything
that's happening please I really really
got into it in the beginning and then I
think I yeah I think there's a line in
the movie where some people are gonna
leave it and some people are gonna stick
with it I think that's where we depart
it's I think we're both on the same page
for a while I mean the movie starts off
with my two least favorite things
ill-mannered houseguests and partners
who don't listen and so like I was
already in I think I wanted it to be a
different movie and when it turn and
again this is definitely one of those
movies where it's like this is a
talkback we're you know we're not doing
like an actual critical review we're
literally just less of theaters yeah so
yeah this is it's these these are the
harder ones for me because I'm like I'm
definitely someone who needs to sit and
think about stuff for a while so I'm
sure there we've done a couple of these
videos were a couple of days later I'm
like you know I regret making that
comment
I don't actually believe that anymore it
was just how I felt at that moment this
is literally just the theater didn't
even speak about it in the car because I
was just saying yeah I think all I said
was I think we're gonna have a
contentious room back on this one and in
film school I had to deal with a lot of
students who made films where the ending
made no sense and their excuse for it
was well let's just open to
interpretation and I got so angry about
that all the time that I think I have a
natural react like negative reaction to
that as a concept and I also I think
that I think probably most people are
going to go to this film be like that
was pretentious as crap and like oh like
okay so hilarious we're so for sitting
there a movie started and this woman
comes in with her phone flashlight
blaringly looking for seeds and we're
just like okay so she finally sits down
she sits she gets up she sits again
then somebody comes in with their phone
on flashing blaring with he proceeded
and wouldn't you know it she waves her
head to get there it's so beautiful so
they sit together then they sit and
they're like you know what this just
can't work so they get up move behind us
to the very back of the theater and for
ten minutes
seems like you're filing paperwork what
are you doing that's not the sound
popcorn makes I talked about I thought
they were making out with the popcorn
bag in between them the second that the
credits rolled the second it happens
movie ends credit rolls he shoots out of
his charities like let's go that so like
I said there are levels of reception
most people are not going to enjoy this
and I never liked films like this ever
for some reason the the interpretation
that I kind of saw with like how the
theme affected them I loved that line at
the end where she's like you never loved
me you just left how much I loved you
and it was such a it just all really
that worked so every story wise
I don't really know how I feel about it
but it's like that kind of so the ending
where we find out he's God retro
actively made me hate the part I hated
the most last but then it made me hate
that part more because like everything
like escalates and there's like war and
there's like sex slavery and all and
murders and all the stuff going on I'm
like and I'm just like this is so many
sharks we've jumped at this point and
it's insane and then when it's God it's
like oh it's about humanity and the love
of God and God's love and and how he
wants us to worship Him but then there's
all these horrible atrocities etc etc
and so the Prophet said then that made
me be more fine with the jump the shark
jumping because it me really because we
jump the hole the greater shark of
humanity then it's like oh no it's just
a heavy-handed allegory for like
religion oh god I'm dense I just
realized the babies Jesus I will say not
some totally trash music I really did
enjoy when she reads the poem that he
writes and he and and they don't like
they don't read the poem out loud
instead we get a visual representation
of how she feels reading the poem I did
like that it's always the weirdest thing
in movies or TV shows when it's supposed
to be this like brilliantly written
thing and then it's only as good as like
the writer who can write it I think in a
in a good sense
it is a movie that's gonna keep people
talking so like that's I mean regardless
of if it's good or not like as a
filmmaker and like your films making
people speak and like talk about about
it and film I think that's kind of cool
about the movie it the acting was
incredible uh-huh it's really pretty
sure oh and it's enraging whether you
like the arrangement or you don't that
is this question let us know what you
think thank you for watching
[Music]